Microsoft is trying to sweeten the deal
with PlayStation to get its Activision
blizzards deal through by allowing its
competitor to put Call of Duty on
PlayStation Plus if the mega Blockbuster
franchise were to fall under its purview
this news from Bloomberg comes after the
acquisition has hit several major
roadblocks including a lawsuit against
the Xbox manufacturer by the Federal
Trade Commission itself so far Sony's
effort to make it appear that Microsoft
would have a monopoly on video games if
the deal were to happen seems to be
working telling anyone that will listen
seriously I heard Jim Ryan is just going
door to door now in a Grassroots
campaign oh hang on a second I just
gotta I just gotta respond to this
foreign
[Music]
sorry never mind it was just Spam anyway
Microsoft has made some unprecedented
announcements and deals to make it clear
that they don't want Call of Duty to be
an exclusive franchise including
offering both PlayStation and Nintendo
10-year deals to put the franchise on
their consoles with the cherry on top
now reveals that PlayStation could put
the series on its own Subscription
Service as of this recording reports
states that PlayStation has yet to take
either offer in its negotiations with
Microsoft if you're wondering how the
Fallout of this deal will affect you it
might help to know just how much Call of
Duty you currently play on playstation
and thanks to an end-of-year stat
tracker you can the PlayStation 2022
wrap-up lets anyone on PS4 or PS5 access
their highlights from the past year
which includes number of games played
total hours played number of trophies
earned and number of PlayStation plus
monthly games downloaded these stats
will continue to track through the end
of 2022 so whatever figures you see
today could change before the start of
the New Year users who complete all
sections of the wrap-up will get a
voucher code to redeem an astrobot
avatar there are six in all and they
will be themed around your personal
stats codes can be Redeemed by others so
Sony is encouraging users to share with
friends you see that code on your screen
that I didn't even blur out I didn't
have to because anyone watching can use
it to claim the astrobot to cross God of
War Avatar so in total I spent a grand
total of 241 hours playing my PS5 this
year with a whopping five hours of those
being spent online and zero hours was
spent playing Call of Duty there sorry
Sony your double XP incentives were
enticing but I can't be caught playing
card on a dual sense when I own an Xbox
and an Elite Series 2 controller if
you're looking to boost those
end-of-year wrap-up numbers for
PlayStation then you might want to take
advantage of several deals on
Playstation games currently running
Ratchet and Clank Rift apart one of the
best games of last year and one of the
ps5's few exclusives is only 30 dollars
at Best Buy in GameStop right now which
is the same price you can get Ghost of
sushima direct his cut at both those
Outlets as well if you're less a third
person action adventure gamer and more
into racing this year's Gran Turismo 7
is 40 at both those locations as well as
Amazon make sure to head to gamespot's
Deals page for more info as well as
additional sales such as the one Gog is
having at the moment that includes over
4 500 titles like cyberpunk 2077 and The
Witcher 3 which is on the cusp of
getting its next-gen update how many
hours did you put into your PlayStation
this year let us know in the comments
below and we'll see you here for more
foreign
[Music]